does anyone know do you smoke fentanyl
or Daphne do you smoke mental or snort
it all right the point is I'm pretty
sure Nancy Pelosi's on fentanyl because
listen to this
Joe Biden is a person of Gantt Vision
knowledge judgment
strategic thinking to get the job done
he was a remarkable two years a
remarkable two years and again connects
very empathetically with the American
people so I hope he runs I'm formed if
he runs and I know that the Democrats
will fully Embrace him if he runs it's
over you remember that scene and When
Harry Met Sally when uh what's her name
Meg Griffin Meg Griffin is that the girl
When Harry Met Sally it was Billy
Crystal and Meg Ryan Meg Ryan they're
sitting at uh I think it's cantor's Deli
in New York City and she fakes the
orgasm and she's fake and the orgasm
everyone's looking at her then the old
lady looks at her is a very famous line
like back in like 88 89 something like
that I'll have what she's having I kind
of want whatever Nancy Pelosi's on to
see the world in such a bang-up opposite
way all the time and get out there and
sell that Vision you gotta kind of
admire it and distinguish he's a man of
vision and he can see things and he's
great oh
[Music]